flight to new york jfk
giulio castaneda is flying to new york
and before he can board his flight
he has to prove that he's covid free you
download the app on your phone
it has all your information this is aok
pass
a digital health passport that verifies
whether someone has tested negative for
the coronavirus or gotten inoculated
it's also known as a vaccine passport
and meant to be easier to use and more
reliable than paper immunization cards
medical results often are not even
printed in a way that it's easy to
to to interpret our system can verify
health records
since the pandemic has devastated the
travel industry airports in rome
paris and singapore as well as airlines
like jetblue and united
are experimenting with similar apps they
will compete for a slice of the global
market for travel health services and
certifications
which aokpas estimates is worth nearly
20 billion dollars
travel industry experts say this type of
digital health certificate
could be a game changer not just for
tourism but live events and schools
so here's how digital health passports
work
travelers who weren't able to take a
coven 19 test before departure at this
airport in rome
can get swapped at a testing site set up
by the airport
while waiting for the result passengers
can download the aokpas
app and input their personal information
like their birthday and email address
within 30 minutes the result is
available if the traveler tests negative
the app creates a unique qr code that
serves as proof
the doctor's scanning like the qr code
that says that you're negative and
you're good to go
at the airport in rome it has to be
scanned at check-in and boarding
i think this is the only way really
right now to travel like safely
without like risking contracting kobe
some but not all airlines and
governments require proof of a negative
test before a passenger is allowed to
board a flight
or enter a country while testing and
vaccinations reduce the risk of
spreading the virus
they don't eliminate it in the setting
of covid19
health information is beginning to be
used
in a transactional sense much more than
before
chester drum is a doctor at the national
university hospital in singapore
and co-founded aok pass he expects that
in order for people to return to
pre-pandemic life
they'll have to show proof of their
health status let me show you part of my
medical record to get on an airplane
let me show you that i've had a
vaccination procedure in order to go
to an event for example this has also
meant forgeries
for instance last november seven people
in paris were arrested and charged with
selling fake coven 19 test results
that cost as much as 360 dollars
drum says the app fights counterfeiting
using blockchain technology
so that the test result and vaccination
certificates are unique and linked to
only one individual
the remarkable thing about blockchain is
once it's entered you can't change it
while blockchain-backed apps may prevent
fakes there could be data leaks
they pose a variety of essential
questions
for the protection of data privacy and
human rights
anna badewski is a researcher who
studies the ethical implication of
digital health data
police makers should require digital
health passport providers to
adopt appropriate technical and
organizational measures
to address potential data privacy
invasive situations
proactively public health researchers
have found that some people in india and
indonesia who tested positive and had
their results disclosed
were verbally attacked or socially
excluded in the u.s the centers for
disease control and prevention
recommends that community leaders and
public health officials
maintain the confidentiality of test
results to avoid social stigma
aokpas says it encrypts all personal
health information
and tries to keep to a minimum the data
it collects on its users
the company also said it does not
monetize data but has signed contracts
with airports and airlines to develop
and test the system
after nearly 10 months of testing aok
pass is scheduled to launch in all major
italian and french airports by the end
of february
it will have to compete with other
companies developing a similar tool
united and jetblue are preparing to use
an app developed by the world economic
forum
called the common pass while ibm is
creating a digital health pass using
blockchain
drum says figuring out the technical
parts of the digital health passport
were relatively easy
compared with making sure the app would
be used along each step of the travel
process
what's hard is the coordinated process
starting with a laboratory in a
different country creating a foreign
medical record
boarding an airline another highly
regulated industry
and then crossing an immigration gantry
which itself
is regulated by the rules and
regulations
of a country different than where you
got your your health test
when castaneda arrived in new york for a
layover on his way to dallas
he says airline staff didn't ask to see
proof of his health status
the rome airport authority said they're
educating travelers about the app
and plan to reach out to airlines
despite the patchy use of the app
castanada says the digital health
passport is a game changer
last time i traveled to the states was
march of 2020 right before the pandemic
hit so it's i mean it's nice to travel
[Music]
again